Morning
everybody. It's uh Mike. It's Friday the
23rd of uh January and welcome to this
special uh presentation um on the order
flows algo indicator for Ninja Trader 8.
You know, we've got that order flows.
We've got about uh you know over close
to 40 uh standalone indicators and you
know traders been asking me to go a
little bit more in depth on them and I'm
going to try to do you know a once a
week uh you know sort of run through of
the of a specific tool and uh you know
I'm not starting alphabetically but uh
with the algo but you know it's it's a
uh it's a great tool for um
understanding you know supply and demand
levels in the market. And let's just
jump into it really quick. You I'm not
going to go run through, oh, my name is
Mike Waltos. You know, most of you are
familiar with me. You know, I mean, you
could just search me up. Uh, you know,
I've got a lot of experience in the
markets. You know, I've worked for JP
Morgan for 10 years, commerce for four.
Um, you know, I started on the CME
floor. So you know [clears throat] I I
have a lot of experience in the markets
and in trading and trading with uh
orderflow as well as different uh ways
of trading in the markets as well. So
the uh orderflow algo indicator
runs on ninja trader 8 and it's
fundamentally based on detecting supply
and demand and then couples it with
order flow. Now, what makes this
indicator kind of unique in the
orderflow sense is it's designed to run
on a normal candlestick. Um, ideally,
it's designed to run without tick
replay. Now, you could run it on a
footprint chart, but since there are a
lot of zones that uh can be drawn on a
chart, especially if uh you know,
depending on the settings and depending
on the market that you're looking at,
your chart could get messy. And you
know, and if you have a chart that's
messy, it just it doesn't help your
trading at all. Instead, it just uh
confuses you even more. So, you know, we
we designed it to run on a candlestick
chart specifically. Um that's why tick
replay is not enabled. You know, a lot
of traders always say, you know, tick
replay screws up their PC, you know,
slows it down, etc. Um, and that was
something that, you know, when when we
were designing this tool,
it was just sort of, you know, hey, can
we can we do this without using tick
replay?
And and we were able to do it. Now,
just really quick, um, you know, some
traders don't understand this, right,
with Ninja Trader,
every version of Ninja Trader has its
own unique uh machine ID, okay? And you
know usually a lot of uh tools you know
indicators etc are linked to that
machine ID. So if it changes and it can
change on simply a Windows upgrade um
and then the next time you log in to
Ninja Trader it created a new uh Ninja
Trader ID um you would need to update
your license. Okay. And you know there's
two ways of doing it. We have uh we have
a link that you can do it yourself if
it's just uh a machine ID
update, but if you were to ch change um
a PC, that would create a new license
token and then you just email me to get
the new license token. So, let's take a
look at the ALGO in action. Uh so, yeah,
now I'm going to run through the
settings, but this for example, this is
uh this is mini DAO today. Okay. And
let me get some crosshairs up here. You
can see the levels being drawn. Now,
with the levels, there's
sort of two parts to it. Okay? There's a
zone that's being drawn out. If it's
red, that's your uh resistance. If it's
blue, that's your support. Okay? Now,
where there's a triangle that appears
is when the [clears throat] conditions
are met for
that zone to be drawn out. Okay? So,
it's not as simple a case when when
you're drawing out supply and demand,
right? It doesn't come out of just one
single bar by itself. Okay? It's sort of
an accumulation of trading that's taking
place. So from the start. So for
example, let me make this crosshairs a
little darker just so it's easier to
see.
All right. So
like right here, right? This is the
start of the zone, but the triangle's
here. It's all this order flow that took
place from here to here. This is where
the triangle came out telling you, you
know, to get short. Just as over here,
it's not just there was just this one
little bar that told you, hey, you know
what? There was uh support or
resistance. uh being formed here. It's
sort of the accumulation that started
here and ended here. That's where this
triangle is telling you, hey, you know
what? It's solid. It's solidified. Um
based on what we saw over the last x
amount of bars, um you know, whatever
the calculation goes into it, conditions
were met, then it will draw the
triangle. Okay? And you're going to use
these zones as um there's two ways to
use them, right? One as obviously
support or resistance and and two as a
stop level. So this is today, you know,
this is yesterday. So there's going to
be some times where,
you know, the zone is drawn out and the
triangle is closer. There's going to be
some times where it's a little further
away. There's a more of a move. It
really just depends on the market and
sort of the settings. You know, this
day, not a lot really going on. This was
the Greenland day where Trump says, uh,
we're going to impose tariffs.
And you know, like I said, sometimes
you're going to be a little closer.
Sometimes it's going to be a little
further away. You know, I I wish there
was a simple way that, oh, this one bar
traded here and you could say, yeah,
that is a demand zone. But it it's, you
know, think about it, right? How how are
you going to measure demand? Can't
measure it off of one bar that traded at
uh, you know, 8:41 p.m. at night to draw
out a level. It takes some trading uh
back and forth, you know, between buyers
and sellers, aggressive buyers,
aggressive sellers into passive buyers,
passive sellers for the to pick up that,
hey, you know what, we've got some
support or resistance being formed here.
Okay? And again, you know, this is
I'm going to talk about the settings,
okay? But just really quick, I'm I I got
I got examples of the settings. Um the
default, right? So the main setting is
strength of of one. Okay. But I want I
want to discuss this later. But
you could adjust this and and I'll show
you on the charts later, but like there
there's certain levels that I like to
use, right, for strength value. Um I I
don't like too many signals. I I prefer
um you know, signals
that have big bigger moves to them
rather than a lot of signals. I'd rather
have fewer with bigger moves like you
saw here in the mini Dow. This is um
what is this? British pound, right? You
got some nice signals, you know, some
longs off this low. You know, short
here, another long here. And again, you
you can see how these levels are
holding. Okay. Now, [clears throat] how
some people trade this is, you know, you
have your zone that was formed, right?
Started here, confirmed here. Look how
this market came right back into this
zone. We actually formed another zone
within the zone as well. Okay,
you know, it's an area where some
traders like to buy or potentially sell,
right? These zones,
you know, looking for a pullback into
it, right? Here's you got a pullback
here. Look at this. You had the zone
drawn out here. Where' we come up to? We
came right up to here.
Okay. I mean, that's today. I mean, see
yesterday, right? just a big straight
run up in the British pound from you
know from this signal here around what I
don't know that came in 26 27 28 29 get
all the way up to you know 90
you had a zone that was drawn out here
we sort of came back to it just
overextended a little bit then it sort
of held
right you see the move down moved back
up and it pulled right back into that
zone here it pulled back into the zone
ran into one here. Bullish signal,
bearish signal. Um, you know, ultra
bonds.
Okay, this is with the same setting I
just showed you like in in the YM
British pound. This is ultra bonds,
right? You can see you got overlapping
zones here. You got one zone, two, even
a third one. You know, it's a nice move
down from basically 11810 down to, you
know, below 118 even where you run into
a support level and you see the market
sort of trading back up into where you
have those resistance areas. You know,
that's today. What yesterday look like
you yesterday off this low up up demand
demand demand. just here you got supply
supply.
All right, so let's take a look at uh
[clears throat]
sort of the settings. Okay, so I showed
you some charts, but let's take a look
at the settings and sort of break it
down here. So
there's not a lot of settings that you
really got to worry about. Uh but the
parameters
um you see up here parameters orderflow
analysis is really the only things you
got to be concerned with. So
supplementary zones hide supplementary
zones you know there are extra supply
and demand zones that are generally seen
in trends as opposed to more traditional
supply and demand zones being generated
at swing highs and swing lows. Um so the
next one is we color the pullbacks was
when it's enabled default is enabled.
So, what you're seeing on here is the
defaults. Um, the zone will recolor,
meaning you're going to see the color in
a slightly different color. All right?
And that's important for when the market
is
um, you know, retracing, okay? Or or
trading back into it. It's going to be a
lighter color. So, for example, what was
where was I before British pound? Um,
[sighs]
you see when it says recolor, it doesn't
like repaint. It just shades the color
differently. So, if it got through it,
it's like this. Even though there was a
zone drawn out here, right? It got
through, you know, 21 was the low of
this zone. It got through down to 20.
That's why it's this really lighter
color. This darker color the market
never came back to. this color where
traded into it is sort of in between. So
you're gonna have three basically three
colors, you know, the the base color
where the market doesn't trade back into
it.
The medium color where the market trades
back into it and this really lighter
color where the market trades through
it. Okay, so for example,
this one. Okay, so you had this would
have been a darker red.
Okay, but we traded back into it. So it
changed the color here, right? So it
made it a lighter red. Then obviously
later we got through it. Okay? So that's
why you see this blue zone is a darker
color. But when I talk about recolor,
that that's what we mean. It it doesn't
change it like from blue to red or
anything like that. But it really deals
with uh the pullbacks
supplementary pullbacks. Supplementary
zone will recolor
to a different color. Okay? Okay, so
this will highlight when a market is
pulling back into a supplementary zone.
Okay, so let's just go back here because
this supplementary zones is linked to
the hide supplementary zones. So let's
get our chart back up here.
[snorts]
Okay, so you see it hide supplementary
zones is not enabled. Okay, so if I want
to hide it, I just enable that.
And you can see that there are some
zones on the left
of the chart that are no longer there. I
could be wrong. Where are they?
So if you uncheck that, how does that
look?
Okay, there we go.
So, you see how this color is the
cyananish color?
This is a supplementary zone.
Supplementary zones
are I forgot how to describe them now.
there like there's zones that
uh I got to look it back up. So it's
like this color and this color. Okay. So
if I
do that, right? So if I hide the
supplementary zones, you see it's not
there anymore,
right? just as this one.
And it had to do with it retracing back
into it
is what the supplementary zone is, I
guess.
Okay. But we sort of combined it into
the into the whole thing. All right. So,
um,
where am I here?
All right. All right. So, the strength
setting. Now, there's choices on here.
There's a drop down menu. There's three
choices. Follow minute-based chart,
normal trading, longer time frame
trading. So, normal trading will work on
most charts. Tick based, time based,
volume based, etc. Um,
and it'll work with uh
anything basically. And the minute based
charts is to be used strictly with
minute-based charts like 1 minute, 2
minutes, 3 minute, 5 minute, 15 minute,
etc. Longer time frame trading is to be
used with longerterm views like hourly
charts. So when you're going on longer
term charts,
if you if we were to change this
here, now there might not be any
signals, okay? Cuz I'll set the strength
value to one. I mean, there might be
some, but it's it's more of a longer
term chart. So you see the bearish, the
bullish. Obviously, when you start
messing around with the settings, you
know, setting it stronger on a longer
term chart, um
it might not come in there. Okay. So,
if you're on
minute-based chart, this will follow
whatever you know, if it was like a one
minute would be your your strength
value. Okay?
So they'll probably be you see it up
here it says calculating um
that will give you a lot of signals okay
and
again normal trading will work on most
charts okay time base tick volume etc
what I I I generally keep it all always
in normal trading I I don't really look
at the the longer time frame trading um
I just adjust the uh strength value to
me that's that's the main one that I'm
always looking at to adjust is not the
uh not the other things. So for example
here right getting back this was
using minute-based chart
okay so you see a lot of signals um
you know you could adjust it to you know
sort of a different number three
cuz when when you click adjust it to uh
follow minute based chart, you know,
when you set it to three, it's going to
follow, you know, sort of a a three
minute chart on here. Okay? Whereas when
you're on normal trading, it's reading
it's reading a different aspect. That's
part of the algo. Okay? I'm not going to
get into that. But again, strength value
is is the one most important one. Um,
you know,
and when I when I go through chart
examples, we'll talk about sort of the
settings that I like. you know, there's
one, there's three, there's five, seven,
you know, is nice. Cleans it up nicely
as well. You know, you you don't want to
be overwhelmed with a lot of signals,
right? And, you know, because that that
just sort of defeats the the purpose of
sort of any trading indicator. You don't
want to set it so low that it's
indicated, you know, giving you signals
all all
the time. Okay.
All right. Uh, next one is the uh again
here just talking about the strength
settings.
The higher the value, the higher the
requirements for the zone to be drawn.
Default set to one. The range of the
settings 1 to 30. A value of one is the
base, which is a good starting point. As
you go higher in value, there'll be less
signals. My favorite settings are 1 2 3
7 and 15 when using normal trading.
Now, the spine demand min and max. Okay,
default is set to two for the min.
And what that does is how it basic it's
part of the algo. determines how many uh
how few price levels a zone needs to be
qualified as a supply zone. Setting is
two sufficient for most markets. A
setting four or five is strong. And this
range can you can set it to zero,
right? The range you can set this at
zero to any number less than the demand
zone. So you're not going to set the min
higher than the max, right? The min is a
is a lower boundary. The max is an upper
boundary. Okay? Okay, if you set it to
zero, it disables the setting. And
honestly, if you set it to zero, you're
going to get a lot of signals, right?
So, you're probably not going to want to
do that. This is a nice band 2 to 25 um
is is good enough, right? I got some
notes here. If you want to set it a
strength value,
the one right above it, to say a number
like three or five or seven, maybe you'd
want to try to set it to zero. Okay? on
volatile markets might want to set it to
a little bit higher like five.
Now for the max zone right the default
is set to um 25. So how many price
levels a zone needs to be qualified as a
supply or demand zone. And technically a
demand zone or supply zone can be made
up of as many price levels as possible
if you want to take in enormous amount
of data. But you don't necessarily want
to do that right? You don't want to take
in an overwhelming amount of data that
uh
you know it's think of it like
net, you know, like a fishing net,
right? Generally fishermanmen have a net
of a certain size. Yeah, you could have
a gigantic net and scoop up all the
fish, but it's going to be very hard to
pull them in, right? And same thing, you
know, setting a a max that's like super
high like, you know, for NASDAQ, maybe
you could you could try it at 50 or
something. But, you know, for most
markets, you don't need to go up that
level, right? But if you set it to like
say 50, um, you know, that takes into
account some of the volatility that's in
the market. So, if it's a market that
has high volatility, okay, but for most
markets, um, you can just keep it at,
uh, 25.
Signal offset in ticks is how far away
from the bar up or down triangle is
drawn on the chart. Okay, so default is
two. Now the orderflow analysis. Okay,
default is enabled. So when enabled
takes the orderflow analysis into
account. It ranges one to five. Can't be
zero. If you know sometimes people think
well I'll set it to zero to disable it.
If you want to disable it just click the
button that says enable. So when it's
unchecked then it's not being used.
setting of one is the strongest.
Three is sort of the the mid-range. It's
the average. And five is the most
liberal. So, when you set it at five, um
you know, you're going to get a lot of
signals. Um not as much as you'd get at
setting of uh disabled, but when it's
enabled, five is the most uh generous.
And of course, you can also use settings
of two and four. Okay? But you know 135
is plenty. Um the data series the
visuals you don't need to touch that
this just data series is what chart type
the algo is running on. Visual is how
the algo is plotting on the chart. Okay.
The alerts if you want to have a sound
alert go off when a signal is generated.
You can enable it from the alerts here.
Okay. Now there's a couple other little
unique settings to this indicator. zone
and price is their stop. When you enable
this setting, the price will appear on
the chart. If price breaks this level,
the supply demand zone is invalidated.
So you can see it's default is disabled.
Zone height and tick is disabled. Start
price
is enabled, right? It says add-on. So
zone end price is basically the other
side of the zone. So like the bottom of
the
of a of a [clears throat] blue zone or
the top of a red zone, that's where
you'd place your stop. The zone height
and thick is how many [snorts] ticks
tall a zone is, right? It measures it.
So, you know, some zones can be three
ticks, some can be eight ticks. It that
just puts the number next to it. Um,
some people like some people like to
look for thick zones, you know, zones
over a certain amount of ticks. That's
why we have that in there. um zone start
price is the upper edge of demand zone
or the lower edge of a supply zone. So
basically if it's a blue zone, it would
be the the top level and it it'll say
the price at the side of the bar. Um and
for a supply zone,
right, the red zone, it would be the the
lower level, right? And and that's a
level it basically all that does is just
tells you all that does is just tells
you the price. Um because when you look
at it here,
where's my chart?
Okay, so [sighs]
you see here 13474.
So I know,
you know, this is the price. That's all
it tells me is here. Okay. So if I were
to enable those other two things here.
So
zone end here zone end price which is
the stop zone height in ticks right zone
start price is the add-on meaning I'd be
looking to add on below 74 okay so if it
trades below 71 that's where I'm going
to have my stop right so it's just a
visual thing and then you can see how
thick the zones are like this zone down
here is 18 price levels from 04 to 22.
This is three from 71 to 74. And again,
you know, sometimes traders, there's
some traders, they they like to look at
zones,
how strong they are in terms of um
you know, how many price levels it
covers, but that that's what those are
for.
Okay. Now, there's the colors. And
again, you can adjust it. I don't think
you need to. Um demand zone pullback is
blue. Then you got dark blue for the
normal demand zone. Supplementary zone
is is cyan.
The border is uh black.
Supply zones is red. Supply zone or the
pullback is red. The normal supply zone
that's not traded back into is dark red.
And the supplementary zone is magenta.
Again, the border is black. Text color
is black. Okay. The opacity is set to
0.3. I mean, you can set it to, you
know, if you wanted to, you can set it
to, I guess, one, which would make it
really the true colors. If, you know,
cuz people say, well, you know, these
colors are kind of light. Um,
you know, if if you ramp it up to
just like 1.0.
Okay. So, you're going to see some of
them are darker. Okay.
back to 0.3. Okay. Again, it's up to
you. You know, the color scheme is
something you can adjust. Um, the setup,
you know, you don't touch that setting.
It's how it's how it's calculated on
each tick. The label is, you know, what
appears on the upper corner of the
chart. And then lastly is the plots,
right? You click these triangles, you
know, the buy signal, the sell signal.
Um, I like blue for buys. Obviously, you
know, that's industry standard. Red for
sells. Okay.
All right. So, using the uh orderflow,
I'll go. Now,
the settings. Now that we've discussed
all the settings, right, let's just jump
into adding it onto your chart. Okay.
So, the default settings, which are
sufficient for most markets, right? This
is your standard starting point. The
settings that you can adjust are
strength value or the ones you can
adjust a lot of settings, but the ones
that you really got to focus on, the
ones that you're going to matter the
most to you is uh strength value, supply
and demand min, and supply demand max.
Orderflow strength. Okay, so remember
the base setting for the strength value
is one. It can't be zero. You cannot set
it at zero. The higher you go, the more
data is analyzed in determining supply
and demand zones. People, well, why why
can't I set it at zero? Well,
why would you, right? It's not going to
work at zero. Well, I want to disable
it. Well, then just remove it from your
chart. Um, the values I like to use are
1 2 3 7 and 15 and five. I mean, I guess
you could add five in there. Um, but
again, you know, you could use whatever
you want. Maybe you want to use, you
know, and I know some people like to use
fib numbers. Um, you know, so you could
use a fib number, but basically, you
know, it just comes down to looking at
the chart, figuring out what chart, you
know, not what chart, what uh based on
the chart that you're trading, what's a
good level for settings. Okay? [snorts]
You can go
to 15, but I don't think it's necessary.
If you want to go very high, change the
normal trading to a longer time frame.
Okay? Cuz if if you're on a sort of the
normal time frame, if you're on a normal
time frame, you have a setting very
high, um,
you know, you just might as well just
use a longer time frame setting.
Now, supply and demand min, think of the
setting as thinness of the zone. So,
ideally, you want to have a zone with
some meat on the bones, right? You don't
want to have a zone that's just um based
off of one
one price level, right? You want to have
it over over a few price levels and
two is a good starting point. Okay? And
it's good for most markets.
Okay? You don't have to use a lot of
different uh you don't really need to
adjust it. Okay? Same thing with uh
supply and demand max, right? You don't
need to go over a 100, right? Um
because basically if you go over 100,
it's going to make your zone bigger,
which is not necessarily something that
you want to do, right? You don't want to
you don't want to be having these zones
that are just drawn so gigantically that
you know it's sort of not price is out
of the market but again you know it's
let me get a chart here.
Okay. I don't know what is this. This is
uh British pound. So uh just show you.
So again it's set at 25. You know I
don't know if I set it at 100. I I don't
know what it's going to look like, but
you know, you're seeing some bigger
zones being drawn
potentially. Well, this is like like
this zone goes from uh 78
down to 50
three. That that's literally
20 25. So, it's like really right on the
border, but you you get my idea. So if
you had a 100, you know, maybe the
zone's going to be from 53 up to, you
know,
you know, 16 or something like that. You
you don't want to have such a gigantic
zone is, you know, is sort of the point
I'm trying to to make. I mean, if you're
on um
well, I don't know, try mini dowo here.
Okay. Yeah, you don't really see that
much. You know, this one, this zone
doesn't look that big, this one right
here. But you can see it's it's 88
ticks. This one is 74 ticks. Uh maybe
you don't want to have it. But then some
people like, well, if it's such a big
zone, 88 ticks, then maybe it's going to
be stronger. Okay, fair enough. I I
understand that. But if you're trading
it, you know, a pullback
into the zone right from the upper level
of 58.
Okay? You know, 48858,
you can you withstand a a draw down to,
you know, 4802
over 50 point draw down. Maybe, maybe
not. You know, because your stop is, you
know, if you're buying it on a pullback
in here, you know, 54, you know, your
stop is at 65. You know, it's almost
it's a 80 90 point stop. So, I'm not
sure you want to uh do that, but again,
you know, it all depends on on your
style of trading.
Now the orflow strength we're not using
orflow analysis you'll get the most
signals based on the strength value and
supply demand maxing in settings but by
using the orderflow analysis right
you'll filter out trades that don't have
supporting order flow that confirms the
supply and demand okay so you [snorts]
can use it without order flow or you can
use it with order flow I prefer to use
it with the order flow okay so when
using orderflow analysis is going to
affect where the signal is drawn on the
chart by a bar or two or or three. Okay,
the signal won't appear in the same
location as it would appear if not using
the orderflow analysis and the strength
values range from one to five. Value of
one is the strongest and you can use two
but three is the average value of five
is the minimum amount of order flow
needed.
Okay, so let's take a look at charts and
see how um the settings
are going to affect how the supply and
demand zones are set. So, this is
just the normal default settings. Okay,
this is uh E- Minis. This a simple one
minute chart uh from a couple days ago.
What day was this? The 21st. Okay, so
every day it's the same chart from the
21st. Okay, but we're going to go
through the settings. So, you see this
is the default settings and it's got
some nice signals, right? It's caught
most of the move up, a little back and
forth in here. Caught a nice move down,
caught the nice move up. All right. And
it signaled right before that big uh
that big rally from you know the say the
64 area all the way up into the you know
6930s when when the ter that was you
know tariff driven but
that's how it looks. Okay. Then we set
the strength value to two. So it's a
little bit stronger. So you see there's
less signals. All right. This is one.
This is two. One. two.
Okay, that's just by going up
incrementally in the strength value.
Okay, now here it's at seven. So, it's
kind of ramped up quite high with normal
trading. You know, there's the blue zone
here. There's the red zone here.
Obviously, you got the blue zone. So,
you got a lot less signals.
Okay,
this is back to the default settings.
Okay, min max. The min is set to two.
Okay, which is the default setting for
the min.
Now, here's where it's set to four.
Okay, so you see there's some thinner
zones up in here from earlier that are
no longer appearing
when you go to four. Okay, so you can
see there was Whoops.
You know, so it's just slightly
incremental. Two, four. Now when you go
to 10, okay, this is from four to 10. So
you see there's this sell signals here
no longer appear there, right? When it
was at four, right? They're there. No,
they're not there. Same as these two
buys up here.
They're gone now.
So what it's doing is this supply demand
min is it's making sure that these zones
are thick enough strong enough
over multiple you know 10 price levels
to give you a zone. Okay that's that's
why at 10 it's stronger than here where
it's these are less than 10. This is at
four actually. So it's one two three
four basically or no it's four to 10.
Sorry. It's got to be a minimum of four.
But
that's why this zone here, which is like
what? Three ticks, is there? This one is
four.
Okay.
Um I I showed you already the the demand
max on the other chart, but um on the
orderflow analysis, so this is it with
it enabled.
and set to three.
Okay, the the default setting, this is
when it's disabled. So, you see there's
there's quite a bit more, right? Focus
here in the middle of the chart, right?
You got the red arrow down, but the bar
right before it has got a buy, just as
up here, you've got a buy, right? You
got some bad trades that you don't want
to take, right? That's why you got to
use the orderflow analysis to clean it
up. So you you're taking higher
probability trades, not trades that you
know there's just you know whatever in
the price action is giving you a signal.
You don't want those trades just as as
here right right before the big runup.
You don't want to be getting short and
then have to get long cuz you know
what's going to happen is I've seen this
with a lot of traders is they're short
off of this signal. Then the bullish
signal comes in. and they're like, "No,
you know what? I'm going to let this
trade run a little bit."
Okay. And then rather than get out,
they're like, "I'm going to give it some
time."
One, they should get out. But two, you
know, they're they're sitting there
playing around with this trade and then
Trump backs off on the tariffs and we
jump, you know, 70 points in the S&Ps.
You know, that that's how a lot of
traders run into trouble is they take
the most recent. And so that's why by
using the orderflow analysis, right,
you're not getting those I hate to call
them false signals, but the the price
action alone signals, right? You want
something that's uh going to be more
active.
Okay?
Again, you don't want every single
signal. You want to sort of start
filtering out by using the order flow.
And then that's what the orderflow
analysis uh setting is for. Okay, this
is where set to one. So, it's a bit
stronger,
right? That's set to five, the weakest.
Now, there will be times where like here
you have the zone drawn, but there's no
triangle anymore, right? See the
triangle like right here?
But now it's gone.
It's because, you know, the conditions
were met
off of
non-order flow analysis. That's why the
zone is still being drawn. But since
there was
no orderflow
confirmation, so to speak, coming in
here, that's why the triangle is not
drawn. But you can still use the zone um
you know, as as a target or as a support
level, but it's not really giving you a
trade signal per se.
Now,
the default settings are good for most
markets. You know, I recommend starting
from there. I like a setting of five.
You know, in these markets, TN ultra
bonds,
British pound,
Japan.
Um,
let's get a chart up here.
Okay. So, what I got there? This is YM.
So here, this set at seven. Okay. But
you know, I don't need to set it at 100.
Keep it back at 25.
Okay.
Obviously,
since yesterday, it's been short.
There's some longs there overnight. Um,
you know,
crude oil
I don't know. We can just run through
some of these markets. This is again
with the same setting of of five. You
can adjust it, right? You don't want to,
like I said, you don't want to have so
many signals that it it sort of defeats
the purpose. But I mean, look at this.
It's catching this big run up all the
way here
to what a supply zone up here. So, if
you're long from way down here, get up
here. Okay, there supply zone. It's time
to get out. Right now, you're getting
long back into some some zones, right?
See down in here? Now, there there's
some
there's some signals that I like more
than others. And one thing that I've
found, and it just unfortunately you
have to sort of be in front of your
machine to see it, is when you have this
sort of
overlapping,
okay, where you got one signal
and then within the same zone, you get
another signal, right? Like you saw
here. in this bar. So, this blue and
this blue, just as down here, you got
this blue and this blue.
Um,
you know, here,
here to a lesser extent here, you got a
lot of signals.
You're running to a big area of
resistance right here, right? This is,
you know, basically 25 up to 50.
And you see the market, you know, sells
all the way down from 20 down to 59.40.
40.
So when when I see these overlapping
zones, to me that's a very strong um
a strong signal.
See any here? Um yeah, that's that's
crude oil. Gosh, I don't know. Now,
let's just take a look here at uh I'm
curious how it looks on gold. Okay. So
now again and gold is pretty volatile
these days. Wow. Almost at 5,000.
But again you know this is with a
setting of
five.
Now I think one of the constraints why
you're not seeing so many signals is due
to the volatility in this market. So if
you were to max make the max a little
bit higher. All right now you're
starting to see some more signals come
in.
All right. There's a nice bullish signal
here cuz you see the zone is 26 price
levels. That's why I wasn't showing
earlier, but you be long from 60 up to
the 80s. Uh,
and it's one is set kind of high. So, I
don't know, bump it down to three or
something.
Okay, so that's a little bit better.
Nice bullish signal here. More bullish
signals there. All right, it catches
this nice move down.
Okay, so there's a question. Um,
a I didn't see your emails. Sorry. Um,
I'm not sure if you're sending them to
the right place, you know, on here.
Let's go back
slides.
This is the best email to reach me at
avaltosyahoo.com
with any questions or help.
Um
Sean asks how is this different from
flow's tips? Well, it's completely
different. It reads very different
aspects of the order flow. Um
and not just order flow. This one also
reads
I say technical analysis but you know we
have a way of drawing support and
resistance levels. Okay, that's why
I see sometimes these where the arrows
are coming in are a little bit spaced
out from where the the zone starts.
Okay, there's a reason for that. Again,
you know, I wish there was just a simple
way, you know, but unfortunately there's
not. If if there was um I would be
talking to you right now. I'd be living
on an island with uh sharks. Well, I
could say just this one bar right here
is my turning point. Out of all these
bars, this one bar is the the the bar
that's turning point. There's not. You
know, anybody that's going to try and
convince you is selling you something.
But
it starts from this bar to up here that
there's enough taking place in price in
volume
everything that says hey you know what
starting from this bar
based on my calculations
this is your support zone here you know
again you know your your long signal is
up here at basically 5, but the the
lower end of your zone is um 19. That's
why, you know, sometimes it's you know,
a lot of traders will trade the pullback
like here, right? This one 33 and a half
is the upper area, right? But it's not
doesn't signal to this bar at 36. So,
you just wait patiently in here for a
pullback cuz, you know, if you could buy
3310,
3320,
then it just it rallies up into, you
know, 10 $10 really quick. This is 4330.
Now, you don't always get the the
pullback that you want, but you see how
these zones, it pulls right to the upper
end of the zone, pulls back up into that
zone.
Okay.
Francis asks, "We updating it with
multi-time frame
tool." Um, you know, it's interesting
interesting question, Francis, because
actually that multi-time frame sort of
was birthed out of this indicator. Um,
when we were working
on this one,
you know, you see the the minute base
chart here
is
so this is like so this is a one minute
chart. So, if I wanted to follow a
minute based chart
of, you know, a 10-minute, give me
10-minute signals based off of the uh
one minute chart. It can Yeah, you know,
we'll probably trying to work in, you
know, volume and and
range and and tick based in the next
update. But uh you know it was from this
one you know that that this was the
starting sort of the starting indicator
um that we sort of cut our teeth with on
on using those those different zones.
Can you show uh NQ with recommendated
recommend recommended settings? Okay. So
this is [sighs]
just go back to normal trading sort of
the defaults here.
Okay, just give it a second here.
I hit enter.
Hang on.
Okay,
just give it a second. MQ, you say the
first time I don't normally keep MQ
open. That's why it's showing up uh a
bit slow here.
So this is
again the default settings one to well I
I ranged I moved it up to 50 instead of
25 in the gold. You know you can keep it
at 25 or you can set it to 50. All it's
going to do is just sort of give you
these bigger zones.
All right. But you see this nice move
down. You know give you a buy signal
here but then keep your short some
longs. I I do believe that,
you know, if it was set at 25, this long
is not going to show. This long is not
going to show. This long is not going to
show cuz it's 40, 44, 43. Um,
but I I wouldn't use one. I'd probably
use like a three or something. Two or
three,
maybe go from there.
Let's see. Okay, so we got less signals
coming in here.
So the shorts, no longs today yet,
yesterday.
Yesterday session, you got the short
here, a long here. This was just right
ahead of the cast session.
overnight is got some stuff going on
there.
This was what day was this? 21st just
the short there. But again, it's with it
set at
normal trading set to three. You know,
again, you know, try two.
If I turn off for analysis that there
will be more signals,
I'd imagine
okay,
you know,
don't think
you know this is today.
So, we got the longs, the shorts up
there. Um,
how's it different from turns? Again,
you know, all these indicators
read different aspects of order flow.
Again, this is really this when we
released this, when we started making
this, it was really a departure from
strictly orderflow.
Majority of all our indicators are
strictly order flow. This takes in other
things to account.
Okay. I mean that's that's hence the
term algo. It's a little bit more
sophisticated um in in what it looks at
not just orderflow but you know levels
that we think that uh are going to
matter the most.
Uh, see any more questions here?
Doesn't look like any more questions.
Let me just Whoops. Where is my thing
here?
So, anyway, guys, um, you know, right
now we got a special deal on it. I I
sent you the link in the in the email.
U, I'm going to include the link. I'm
I'll throw it in the chat here as well.
Uh where's the chat down here?
Let's just go to
order flows
algo. Not orderflow algo, but uh
actually the the the whole term
orderflows algo.
Why doesn't that link show up as a link?
I put it in the chat in the
uh that's why because I put the link in
there incorrectly. So https
colonwwworderflows.com.
There we go.
So
you just take it here.
Maybe I'll post this. These charts are
2023, but it's still the same. You know,
it talks about uh sort of the different
settings. You see here's a 15-minute
chart using longer time frame.
you know, talk a little bit about the
minmax settings
visualization, how to trade into support
and resistance zones.
Okay, [snorts]
it's just 149 right now. This deal is
not going to stick around for long, but
I just want to get because you know
there's some traders talking about it in
um
in the uh strategic traders chat,
Christian was talking about this
indicator unit with point and figure and
you know it it's it's it's a nice tool
for a lot of chart types. So again, this
is the link www.orderflowsalgo.com.
So, take care everyone and I'll see you
guys later. Um, bye-bye.